[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was the animal I most
identify with is Mitt Romney said the
alpha male in a Wolfpack Newt Gingrich
said a pit bull that never backs down
Ron Paul said a tiger shark with no
chance of getting elected president just
hing the last time I got really drunk i
patton oswalt wrote crank called an old
college friend
ryan gosling said had a terrible
hangover the next day
Magic Johnson wrote bought the Dodgers
ala all right better watch it I live
here now
the most common misspelling of my name
is Zooey Deschanel wrote Zooey Sofia
Vergara wrote Sophie Snooki wrote and
Cheetos dust coated SlutWalk
[Applause]
I wish I had a dollar for every Tina Fey
wrote our I've spent at work Joel McHale
wrote autograph I've signed Mitt Romney
wrote billion dollars how did I do that
right the the greatest gift I ever
received was when Javier Bardem wrote I
won an Oscar
Steve Carell wrote I saw the birth of my
children Morgan Freeman wrote my fiance
gave me a world's number-one grandpa my
autobiography would be called Tom Hanks
wrote every man Amy Poehler wrote short
but sweet Andy Richter wrote sidekick to
Satan
[Applause]
[Music]
it that ones that's the one that tested
best with the focus groups nothing
personal okay
yeah all right Hot in Cleveland set says
on Friday right
I've uh I've modeled my entire career on
Paul Rudd wrote Tom Hanks Natalie
Portman Meryl Streep Lindsay Lohan wrote
footage of NASCAR crashes
[Music]
I dream of one day Barack Obama wrote
seeing peace in the Middle East
Mitt Romney wrote restoring America to
greatness
chris Christie wrote using the Hadron
super collider to fire a pie into my
mouth and why would that enhance the pie
eating experience he doesn't care he
just wants to get that pie in there as
fast as possible obviously an adrenaline
and pie junkie
yeah Infanta physics yeah and finally I
hope to headline at this year's fred
armisen wrote Montreal Comedy Festival
Dave crow wrote Bonnaroo Geraldo Rivera
wrote douche by douche West
it's a great festival win take a little
break